hey Shawn thanks for inviting me over to
your desk my pleasure
uh I see that you have the Destiny ghost
edition here that's correct
I brought my space mug I also brought my
space mug it's get it started here we go
first thing you'll notice it's like a
cube but they cut the corners off the
cube so it's not quite cubic anymore
your mastery of geometry is truly
astounding Chris but it's what's inside
that counts when it comes to the $150
Ghost Edition bundle of Destiny so while
we just go ahead and pop this sleeve off
are we are we ages 12 plus basically yes
maybe not mental all right that it
doesn't say emotionally yeah here we go
all right there you go while you take a
good look at that sleeve look here's a
sneak peek of all the stuff that's
inside of it
oh we're gonna look at it now first side
for real first thoughts tactile response
what do you think smooth yeah but it's
got these are like embossed a little bit
yeah yeah run your finger over that one
feels good yeah I'm gonna be honest that
feels good
here we go cool little subtle it off so
immediately what we get is the little
ghost figure here
I believe it's Peter dinklebot Peter
dinklebot yes that is the official
canonically correct nomenclature let's
see if this thing has some juice in it
oh yeah let's say something else say
something say something get the shakin
to say it make him say something I find
that works with people you shake them
and they say never never shake a
Dinklage okay ever do it yeah Joffrey I
like it it's nothing like just zooming
about noises kind of my oldest so on the
back here if you take a look you can see
there's a different settings for him
here as well as a little USB port here
which I assume is for charging it I
wonder if you can like load on different
color profiles to this thing drawing on
one could only hope so it's like
hovering here mm-hmm I'm like oh man
look there's some drugs over here and
it's like dude watch out there drugs
over there and I'm like I got it
dinklebot pow pow pow pow you have to
exercise a little suspension of
disbelief when your ghost companion
to be physically held above your head
but beyond that I would say it's it's
pretty convincing it said this place is
littered with pre Golden Age artifacts
so how would you display this right when
you just kind of sit it I would put it
right next to my slide right there
he says grab everything that isn't
bolted down I'll keep an eye out for
fallen best friends for life
oh look at him he said he's not going
back in the box that's pretty clever
that's alright here we go let's take a
look at always go for the book before
the video game Bashan look books before
games you want to take a look at that
okay so it's got the same seal on the
front which echoes the designs of the
individual class seals the Warlock the
hunter the Titan and then on the inside
all there's all sorts of stuff there's a
Latin I just turn off Peter didn't go
bot quiet down there we go uh all right
so let's take a look first at arms and
armament / dasya odd Ostra the last part
means to the Stars to boldly go to the
Stars it's something probably commonly
written as something else I don't know
there is no after and so oh it's like
one of these little books with like fake
annotations in there so you know it's
like got notes it just I just want you
guys to know quadruple underline be
brave that's that's important you don't
want to not be brave I don't know why
don't not be brave always be not not
being brave either I mean no matter what
those are all great tattoos that you
should get permanently etched on your
body this one's called the hand cannon
oh look last word thorn so it's showing
some of the unique weapons the fusion
rifle obviously pretty straightforward
basic saw that in the beta but then it
gets into nicer little bits this one's
got it and bayonet on the end and this
one's got and I don't know it's
bedazzled with orange stripes there
should be more sparkly guns in this game
some notes about the alien things one of
those guys called fallen the husks once
you have varieties of enemies okay
and it's just all sorts of wonderful
little gun porn and then all drawings of
outfits so you can know what kind of
dressup you're going to be able to play
that's a dope warlock
it feel good you know looking good it's
tight tight Oh
ships and then just like the sketchbook
part where they just drew butts in the
margins and I'm going to go out on lemon
assume there's act no actual but you
don't think there's an alien but in here
a signet one so I don't find anything
sorry guys in addition to that arms and
armament book inside the same little
case here you'll find this sort of
letter of greeting
that's kind of a little a note to would
be guardians who are joining the joining
of forces out there just kind of get get
yourself hyped up get yourself
invigorated ready to take on those
enemies nothing invigorates me like
bring it to the black heart of our
enemies burn away the darkness that
threatens to engulf us once and for all
these are really cool actually these are
actually vintage style postcards you can
see old Russia here Mars is that we hold
on the red planet of Mars there you go
some Russia as well and of course Venus
in a very Art Deco style I like these
nice on the back kind of a pre
distressed a little visual look to them
do you think this would ship with a
normal postcard stamp in the US or do
you have to use a full like forever
stamp I think you could use a regular
regular stamp on that a postcard stamp
on the different stamps people want to
hear about stamps and here we also have
a map of the solar system which has a
very very interesting finish to it very
kind of yet it's smooth but it almost
feels like it's it's like rubbery yeah
so it's it's durable it's kind of like
on the once the aliens came we ran out
of cloth so basically all we can do is
print maps on rubber now yeah
so this is actually kind of echoes the
art style that you saw if you played the
beta when you looked at the map and it
saw you know you saw the map of old
Russia where you're choosing your
missions where you saw the moon it was
locked up for most of the beta it's that
kind of style which i think is cool i
mean it's like a neat sort of blend of
like 18th 17th century kind of aesthetic
like that yeah Age of Exploration uh
that they're sort of trying to evoke
here and use bring date yeah it looks
cool I mean Bungie has always been very
open about the fact that they're trying
to blend fantasy with sci-fi here and I
think this
a little poster here kind of reflects
those two this is for doodling
aesthetics that's also you draw bikes to
your heart's content right there doodle
on that one
there's like an alphabet here that
doesn't have all the letters and has a
few numbers it's like some weird kind of
replacement code situation maybe let's
see it art no I don't know I can't
recognize any patterns because I'm not a
code Smith you certainly aren't so onto
the next item in the box here we've got
this little guy right here with my seal
on the back let's find out
Rick and see what is inside mmm
I did break this seal alright here we go
let's sum up you disc a patch Ares one
air it Fortis a little photo
well polaroid not a selfie that is that
is the first selfie geez whew these are
cool hold it up to a thing hold it up to
the monitor hold it up to gamespot.com
I'm gonna hold this in front of camera
Benson it looks like a black that looks
like a solar eclipse wait a minute yeah
mmm maybe no man come on I got letters
and stuff on it I don't know oh god no I
figured out what these are for and then
of course hold on yeah they're for there
you go nail there for that my I'm
addictive Dougs
macleod rotating looking good Chris
looking real good
well I'm not professional mm-hmm all
right oh okay
I'm serious we're gonna take a little
look at this before we jump into the
game itself
little ghost dongle little Dingle dongle
tinkled there's a dinkle dongle yeah cuz
they're a little dinkle dongle - that's
cool let's see it and press it out let
me see that tinkle mangal okay famous
last words
awkward time to lean down let me see
them dongle all right these are
essentially just instructions for how to
connect your dinkle dongle to your
comfier oh so we're really going with
dinkle dongle is that happening we're
not gonna cut that out it's just dinkle
dongle what all right cool I mean so
what does this do is this so you just
how you charge it it's a charging cable
yeah micro
USB little whatever little quick
reference guide yeah okay all right way
to you know what I think the dinkle
dongle deserves a little bit more
respect than that Chris all right
finally last but not least that's a good
stuff you guys still game case itself
let's take a look open it on up
and of course destiny here on the
PlayStation 4 ray so this is obviously
the ghost edition so it comes with let
me just take all the stuff out of one
ball box art man be careful with the
code inside though comes with a
expansion pass as well so you can get
all that sweet DLC and yeah looks like a
pretty little sweet sweet deal here what
do you got but what are those things
order where these things you what it
let's itemize come on the expansion pass
yeah yeah includes expansion 1 and 2
mm-hmm we've got we have problems like a
30-day trial for PlayStation 2 us health
and seizure warnings and some collectors
edition digital content which comes with
play realm at player emblem Oh Yost
casing and player ship variant right on
yeah hey if any of you actors out there
wanna like you know copy this image and
then just burn it onto a blue right boom
don't do it destiny don't do it ok Mary
uh yes what check this out though
wouldn't look in the box it's actually
like the molding stuff they've got here
is that same sort of destiny codpiece
logo uh I think I was coming you touch
yeah
I'm pretty cool I'm still baffled as to
what these things yeah I mean is this
the traveler coming first person first
person in the comments to let us know
what exactly these things are called in
terms of I mean her actual name just the
travel like before the traveler got all
jacked up and just parked it over earth
no no postcards are we gonna write a
postcard oh you want to hold it behind
it there you go like that so it's done
cool uh we're gonna be writing these
postcards and sending them out to our
grandmothers
that's just how we do we're respectful
gentlemen nice boys that's the ghost
edition Sean Chris thanks for unboxing
that hey what's coming up on Monday Oh
Monday we're gonna playing destiny all
day sounds good see you guys there ting
at 5 a.m. Pacific we're gonna have all
three classes being played
simultaneously we're gonna switch every
hour between the different classes and
just go all day sounds fun all day
destiny I'm really excited I'm have to
go a bit early don't drink too much
coffee